President Biden announced the news in a
tweet releasing a photo of himself vice
president Kamala Harris and Brittany
greiner's wife shirelle speaking to the
Basketball Star as she flew back to the
United States she's safe she's on a
plane she's on her way home after months
of being unjustly detained in Russia
Greiner was arrested in February at a
Moscow airport for drug possession and
smuggling after authorities found Trace
Amounts of cannabis oil in her luggage
she was convicted in August and
sentenced to nine years of hard labor in
a Russian penal colony U.S officials led
by the president condemned her sentence
as disproportionately harsh for months
the U.S has been negotiating with
Russian diplomats to release her what's
your moon
you fly back home to the uh to the U.S
everything will be fine she endured
mistreatment and I showed attitude in a
show trial in Russia with characteristic
grit the White House won't say what
suddenly changed only that this week
brought a breakthrough on Thursday
Greiner was sent to the UAE as part of a
prisoner swap for Russian arms dealer
Victor boot referred to by some as The
Merchant of death he'd been serving 12
of a 25-year sentence in a U.S federal
prison for conspiring to kill Americans
acquiring and exporting anti-aircraft
missiles and providing material support
to a terrorist organization before his
arrest boot had built a business
allegedly supplying weapons to support
Wars and uprisings around the world from
Africa to Afghanistan at the White House
greiner's wife expressed relief her
ordeal was finally coming to an end
Montreal have been
um
so privy to one of the darkest moments
of my life and so today I'm just
standing here overwhelmed with the
emotions but the most important emotion
that I have right now is just sincere
gratitude
but Biden still faces questions about
American Paul Wayland left behind and
currently serving a 16-year sentence in
Russia on Espionage charges his family
says he's innocent sadly for totally
illegitimate reasons Russia is treating
Paul's case differently than Britney's
and while we have not yet succeeded in
securing Paul's release we are not
giving up still there's fear about
President Biden's decision to swap
evicted arms dealer for an American
convicted of drug possession there are
fears it could encourage further hostage
taking and send a global message about
the price the White House is willing to
pay for American lives
Kimberly helken Al Jazeera the White
House